hello everybody and welcome to a new
series on halide halite is an open
sourced artificial intelligence
competition where players from around
the world using just about every major
programming language can compete against
each other and it sort of simulated
space environment so what I have going
on here is just a replay of one of the
many many many games out there and these
little things buzzing around or their
ships and what they're doing is they're
mining planets for resources the more
resources you have the more ships you
have the more ships you have you can
kind of begin to expand and your goal is
to basically take over basically as blue
player has just done you want to be like
blue player so how do we actually get
started with halite so what you're going
to do is head to hell light dot IO
create an account basically it's just
you you combine and you authorize your
github account and boom you've got an
account once you've done that go ahead
and scroll down to the get started here
and at this point we've already done
step 1 in step 2 what we want to do is
download a bot so go ahead and click
here to download the starter kit and as
you can see here a bunch of languages at
your disposal I'm gonna be using Python
3 and then you just sometimes you'll
need to match the operating system
sometimes it won't matter but in this
case windows for Python 3 so I'll hit
download will save the file and once you
have that file I'm gonna go ahead and
drag it over into here I'm gonna extract
it and I'll get rid of this just so it's
not confusing and here we have our
starter files HLT this directory is just
a bunch of helper Python scripts to help
our starter but I'll go ahead and open
the starter bot too while we're talking
about it and this is very well heavily
commented code so I'll let you read
through it also we'll be breaking it
down in a future video but in this get
started let's just assume hey this is a
great starter AI halide Exe is just so
we can run it locally this will read me
of course and these are just two quick
helpers that we could double-click
depending on your operating system I'm
on Windows so I'll use the dot bat but
basically it's just gonna run halide dot
exe with some parameters in this case
it's just setting the dimensions as 240
by 160 and then it's running my bot pi
versus my potpie so let's say we want to
run it locally I'll just double click
this it runs a game games
over already here's a replay file of the
game so as you're developing you're
probably gonna want to run it locally
just to see if your logic is doing what
you hoped it creates these replay files
and one way that we can do replay those
is to come up here to submit a bot and
on the right hand side we can replay a
file so we can just click and drag that
file over and in a moment it replays the
game how it went
unfortunately blue actually both players
eliminate themselves and now we're just
pulling ourselves up so starter bots not
exactly the smartest bot and this
shouldn't happen every time either this
is just what kind of by chance cuz this
is a randomly generated map
it's just unfortunate this is how it
went but anyways let's say that we're
very happy with this logic this looks
like a bot that we definitely want to
compete with what we're gonna want to do
is zip up our bot your bot needs to be
always called in title cased my bot dot
and then whatever the programming
language extension is in our case it's
Python so that's what I'm gonna use and
it's already called that but if you make
like a v2 or something like that
remember before you submit it it needs
to be called my bot PI you'll see how I
get around that if you follow some of my
later videos in this series but
regardless what we want to do is zip it
up this isn't a it's a required to
include for this script so I'm going to
highlight that one as well now what I'm
going to do is send to a compressed zip
folder and you can call it whatever you
want in this case I'm just going to call
it submission zip and now we're gonna go
to submit a bot and I'm just gonna drag
that over this time to the left-hand
side and we'll submit the bottom it says
here your bot will start competing
within hopefully the next 15 minutes but
I've found that it's usually within the
minute and then you can come to see your
results and these are just games you can
click on any of them to to replay them
if you get the lull you have first place
basically you with a little badge here
it makes it quick and easy to see but
you can also see here I got third place
second second second and so on so anyway
you can click on them and we can
actually replay the game to see how we
did
how we want it and I usually actually
find you know it's fun to watch the
games that you won but generally it's
better to watch the games that you lost
so you can
see how did the other player beat you or
what did you do wrong that cost you the
game anyways that's a very quick get
started if you're interested I'm going
to be producing some more videos on how
to start editing this script and then
actually how to make your own so you can
hopefully do a little better in this
competition than just using the starter
bots but otherwise you can just get to
hacking get started and good luck in the
competition and I'll see you in another
video